un pomeriggio buon pomeriggio a tutti
questi sono i giorni del black friday
avete comprato qualcosa io ho preso a
capelli ieri sera
fatemi vedere le mani quanti di voi
hanno il cellulare in mano a chi rendete
conto di quante ore noi passiamo tutti i
giorni con il telefono cellulare in mano
usiamo per cercare le offerte online
quello che stiamo facendo tutti questi
giorni abbiamo tempo ancora fino a
domani volessimo comprare qualcos'altro
poi paghiamo il parcheggio paghiamo nei
negozi
leggiamoci informiamo ascoltiamo musica
guardiamo il film è sicuramente il
dispositivo elettronico che noi
utilizziamo di più non so se vi siete io
mi sono un po vergognata ve lo confesso
guardandolo screen time sul mio telefono
che ammonta diverse ore al giorno mi
viene anche male sgridare le mie figlie
così io sono la prima che passa tante
ore col telefono in mano
comunque non abbiamo soltanto lo
smartphone che sicuramente il
dispositivo che noi utilizziamo di più
abbiamo anche molti di noi lo smartwatch
che ci consente di sapere quanti passi
facciamo tutti i giorni come sono le
nostre pulsazioni di continuare a essere
connessi a vedere le chat di whatsapp e
poi abbiamo sicuramente un computer un
laptop diverse penne usb
questi sono tutti i dispositivi
elettronici e poi ci sono gli
elettrodomestici
tutti noi abbiamo almeno un televisore
un frigorifero lavatrice una
lavastoviglie l'asciugacapelli e così
via
questi sono dispositivi che se noi li
contiamo arrivano essere almeno 20
ognuno di noi utilizza quotidianamente
almeno 20 dispositivi elettrici ed
elettronici
il problema è che questi dispositivi
hanno una vita molto limitata
si parla di 24 anni per i dispositivi
elettronici e informatici e di 58 anni
per gli elettrodomestici
il motivo è che è comunque la tecnologia
va avanti molto rapidamente i prezzi
diventano sempre più accessibili per il
mercato e poi insomma la tecnologia ci
piace ci piace avere dei dispositivi
sempre più performanti sempre più smart
e quindi le apparecchiature elettriche
ed elettroniche che noi chiamiamo a e
diventano rifiuti di apparecchiature
elettriche elettroniche quelli che
vengono chiamati rai
quanti rai vengono generati nel mondo
una quantità enorme nel 2016 questa
quantità era pari a 45 milioni di
tonnellate il numero che è stato stimato
per l'anno 2019 e 50 milioni di
tonnellate e un numero gigantesco se noi
consideriamo tutti gli abitanti del
pianeta
il calcolo ci dice che ognuno di loro
tutti gli anni produce 7 kg di rifiuti
di apparecchiature elettriche
elettroniche questa sala siamo
all'incirca 300 moltiplichiamo facciamo
un rapido calcolo in un anno noi siamo
in grado di produrre soltanto noi
presenti qui oggi oltre due tonnellate
di rifiuti elettrici ed elettronici
immaginateli qui vicino a me sul palco
riempirebbero tutto questo spazio
arriverebbero fino al soffitto in un
solo anno
quali sono i rai che vengono prodotti
se noi facciamo un ragionamento su
quanto pesano quindi sulle abbondanze
relative in massa
l'ottanta per cento dei rai che vengono
raccolti e costituito da grandi
elettrodomestici cosiddetti grandi
bianchi poi tv e monitor e la rimanenza
è data dai piccoli elettrodomestici e i
dispositivi elettronici e informatici
il grande problema è che tutte queste
tipologie di rifiuti vengono gestiti
attualmente in modo non efficiente noi
non riusciamo a tracciare l'ottanta per
cento dei raee immaginiamo che in questo
momento tutti noi tutti noi circa 300
decidiamo approfittando delle offerte
del black friday di acquistare un nuovo
smartphone
ecco allora noi perderemo completamente
le tracce di 240 di questi dispositivi e
riusciremo a intercettarne soltanto 60
quindi esistono dei sistemi di gestione
dei raee all'incirca nei due terzi dei
paesi del mondo
un terzo dei paesi del mondo non ha
ancora al momento una normativa dedicata
a questa tipologia di rifiuti ma il
problema è che i sistemi sono poco
efficienti qual è il problema
fondamentale che queste tipologie di
rifiuti in particolare quelli di piccole
dimensioni vengono gestiti in modo non
appropriato perché vengono smaltiti
insieme ai rifiuti solidi urbani
rispetto ai rifiuti solidi urbani i
rifiuti delle apparecchiature elettriche
elettroniche sono una parte minimale
sono circa il 2 per cento e massa
il grande problema è che essi
racchiudono il 70 per cento delle
componenti pericolose se noi
consideriamo che cosa succede nel mondo
e che cosa impone la legge
quanto meno in europa e in italia
sappiamo che è obbligatorio che ogni
paese vi parlo dell'europa che il nostro
contesto ogni stato membro si doti di un
sistema centralizzato di gestione dei
raee
ad esempio in italia noi abbiamo il
centro di coordinamento rai
il problema è che questo sistema di
gestione al quale contribuiscono tutti i
soggetti coinvolti i produttori di
apparecchiature elettriche elettroniche
coloro che raccolgono i rifiuti coloro
che trattano i rifiuti e li riciclano e
un sistema che risulta poco efficiente
in particolare per quanto riguarda i
dispositivi di piccole dimensioni
la legge impone anche che vengano
riciclati il 65 per cento di dispositivi
elettrici elettronici messi in commercio
nel triennio precedente e che vengano
trattati e riciclati
la 85 per cento dei raid purtroppo siamo
molto lontani da questi numeri che la
normativa ci impone vediamo qui nella
tabella che in europa la situazione
diciamo e
o meno sconfortante rispetto al resto
del mondo ma comunque abbiamo ancora
tanto lavoro da fare
i rai seguono delle rotte internazionali
che hanno anche una lunghezza molto
elevata
i rai che vengono raccolti seguono delle
rotte per via di un mercato che può
essere lecito o anche in certi casi
lecito verso dei paesi che sono diversi
dai luoghi di raccolta e di produzione
dei re stessi vediamo da questa mappa
che questi paesi dei quali rare vengono
trasportati e poi concentrati sono in
generale dei paesi che sono fragili dal
punto di vista sociale ed economico
vediamo l'america latina l'africa il sud
est asiatico
questi sono dei paesi nei quali non è
particolarmente sviluppata una
consapevolezza ambientale e una
consapevolezza riguardo alla sicurezza
per la salute umana e rai sono dei
rifiuti molto particolari perché
contengono sostanze acide contengono
metalli pesanti contengono sostanze
organiche e se vengono gestiti in modo
non appropriato senza protezione degli
operatori
queste sostanze possono creare degli
effetti anche molto seri sulla salute
umana
il problema è che mentre gli effetti
tossicologici dell'esposizione a queste
sostanze nell'immediato sono noti
non sono noti gli effetti tossicologici
a medio e lungo termine sugli operatori
per cui continuare ad avere come abbiamo
al giorno d'oggi centinaia di migliaia
di persone che gestiscono in modo non
appropriato questa tipologia di rifiuti
e come dare a queste persone una sorta
di bomba a orologeria dal punto di vista
sanitario
li stiamo compromettendo la loro salute
ma non sappiamo ancora bene a medio
lungo termine per quanto e in quale
maniera quindi è molto importante
trattare i rifiuti delle apparecchiature
elettriche ed elettroniche in modo
appropriato
quindi come deve essere fatto sistema di
gestione e iran che sia efficiente
e che sia sostenibile aggiungo un
concetto in più deve essere innanzitutto
un sistema nel quale anche chi produce
le apparecchiature elettriche
elettroniche ha una responsabilità
diretta del sistema stesso
la legge sia in italia che negli altri
stati membri dell'unione europea impone
che il produttore delle apparecchiature
elettriche ed elettroniche abbia una
responsabilità che si chiama appunto
extended producer responsibility per cui
il produttore direttamente coinvolto
nella filiera di trattamento
quando noi acquistiamo un dispositivo
elettrico ed elettronico paghiamo già la
quota del prezzo di vendita che tiene
conto della gestione di quella parecchio
alla fine della sua vita
quindi è molto importante riuscire a
separare dal flusso dei rifiuti solidi
urbani
questo tipo di rifiuti e attenzione il
produttore di apparecchiature elettriche
ed elettroniche per legge ha l'obbligo
di ritirare il vecchio dispositivo che
noi vogliamo smaltire anche in assenza
dell'acquisto di uno nuovo
tutto questo è molto semplice perché vi
faccio un esempio che mi riguarda è il
mese scorso dovuto sostituire il
frigorifero perché quello che avevamo e
si è guastato e cosa ho fatto col
vecchio frigorifero è stato molto
semplice
ho prenotato telefonicamente il ritiro
l'azienda locale che si occupa della
gestione dei rifiuti o la cittadino e il
mio free vecchio frigorifero è stato
ritirato sul piano stradale
il giorno seguente gratuitamente
cittadino tedesco per questo stesso
servizio paga una cifra che è compresa
tra i 70 e gli 80 euro
se invece io avessi da smaltire appunto
il vecchio asciugacapelli che
sostituiscono quello che ho acquistato
ieri che ha dato recentemente io dovrei
portarlo lo porterò al centro di
raccolta all'isola ecologica del mio
quartiere che è qui vicino
quindi è molto importante e gestire nel
modo appropriato
questa tipologia di rifiuti gli ho detto
prima che un sistema di gestione dei
raee che sia efficiente deve essere
anche un sistema sostenibile e voglio
citarvi la definizione forse più moderna
sicuramente quella che io preferisco
perché è quella più completa di sviluppo
sostenibile che quella di kate awards
che è una studiosa inglese un economista
che ha sviluppato il modello economico a
ciambella cosa vuol dire lo vedete qui
rappresentato vuol dire che lo sviluppo
sostenibile è un qualcosa che si
sviluppa all'interno di un sistema molto
complesso nel quale intervengono
contemporaneamente elementi di tipo
economico di tipo ambientale e di tipo
sociale tutti presenti
contemporaneamente e con pesi diversi
quindi un sistema di gestione efficiente
e sostenibile e rifiuti delle
apparecchiature elettriche elettroniche
un sistema che deve essere in grado di
intercettare il 100 per cento dei raee
separandoli dai rifiuti solidi urbani
deve essere in grado di recuperare le
componenti dei rai che possono essere
direttamente riutilizzabili
oppure riparabili e riutilizzabili
pensiamo non so alle ventole e motorini
sono tante componenti
tra l'altro questa operazione anche una
valenza sociale molto importante perché
spesso della riparazione dei rai si
occupano delle cooperative che danno
lavoro a delle categorie socialmente
fragili 15 e diciamo un ulteriore
beneficio la gestione corretta dei raid
sistema efficiente e sostenibile dei
raee di gestione dei raee deve essere in
grado di separare le componenti
riciclabili
ad esempio i metalli la plastica il
vetro deve essere in grado di separare
le componenti pericolose che sono le
uniche effettivamente da destinare a
discarica
tutto queste operazioni sono delle
operazioni che permettono di tutelare
l'ambiente di tutelare la salute degli
operatori coinvolti
ma sono anche delle operazioni che
consentono di creare posti di lavoro di
sostenere lo sviluppo economico
e tutto questo è molto importante perché
sono comunque delle leve che non
guardano soltanto le tematiche
ambientali per cui nel complesso tutto
quello che abbiamo detto fino adesso ci
fa capire che la gestione sostenibile ed
efficiente e i rifiuti delle
apparecchiature elettriche ed
elettroniche è pienamente coerente con
le politiche europee sull'economia
circolare e allo stesso tempo anche con
gli obiettivi dello sviluppo sostenibile
dell'agenda 20 30 il trattamento
sostenibile ed efficiente dei rifiuti
delle apparecchiature elettriche ed
elettroniche permette di recuperare
quelle che vengono definite materie
prime secondarie
quindi i metalli soprattutto ma anche
altre tipologie di materie e in più c'è
una particolare categoria di materie
prime quelle che vengono chiamate
materie prime critiche che sono delle
sostanze per le quali l'europa dipende
quasi completamente oppure totalmente da
paesi extraeuropei facciamo degli esempi
le schede elettroniche a circuiti
stampati dei telefoni cellulari degli
elettrodomestici contengono alcuni
grammi di rame e frazioni di grammi di
oro e argento e di altri metalli
preziosi
gli schermi neri dei tv e dei monitor
contengono le terre rare per cui noi
dobbiamo imparare a considerare i
rifiuti delle apparecchiature elettriche
ed elettroniche come dei veri e propri
giacimenti di materie prime secondarie e
rare e stato calcolato che il totale
delle materie prime che possono essere
ricavate ogni anno dai rai nel mondo
ammonti a 55 miliardi di euro per darvi
un'idea di quanto vale questo numero
tenendo presente che in questo momento
in italia si sta discutendo di una
manovra economica da 20 miliardi
qui questo vi dà la misura
dell'importanza economica di questo tipo
di rifiuti per cui concludendo noi
abbiamo ci siamo resi conto di che cosa
voglia dire gestire in modo appropriato
in modo efficiente in modo sostenibile i
rifiuti del
apparecchiature elettriche ed
elettroniche abbiamo visto che cosa
implica fare tutto questo e anche che
cosa implica non farlo abbiamo visto le
conseguenze
abbiamo preso consapevolezza del fatto
che il problema sia estremamente
complesso e che dobbiamo tener conto di
aspetti economici gli aspetti sociali di
aspetti ambientali
il messaggio che io vorrei che voi
portate a casa oggi pomeriggio questo
speech è il seguente il fatto di avere a
cuore l'ambiente il futuro del nostro
pianeta
il fatto di volere che il l'earth
overshoot non sia più il 29 luglio ma
magari si riesca ad arrivare a qualche
giorno di agosto non implica
necessariamente dover tendere a modelli
di decrescita sociale ed economica
avere a cuore il futuro del nostro
pianeta vuol dire essere consapevoli
delle nostre scelte e vuol dire essere
consapevoli delle conseguenze delle
nostre scelte per cui continuiamo ad
approfittare delle offerte del black
friday credo che scadano domani
compriamoci il dispositivo che tanto
vogliamo del quale magari non abbiamo
bisogno ma ce lo compriamo perché ci fa
piacere e facciamolo con gioia però
siamo assolutamente consapevoli che il
vecchio dispositivo deve essere gestito
nel modo corretto o in questo modo
tuteliamo l'ambiente
tuteliamo la salute degli operatori del
settore ma anche creiamo nuovi posti di
lavoro e diamo una spinta all'economia
grazie